vous avez une minute je vous emmène dans
les ivelines à mes dents où une île
oubliée de tout séveille bien des
curiosités l'île du
Platet autrefois un sanctuaire de
détente pour les citadins ce saint tropé
de la scène est aujourd'hui un
sanctuaire du silence où seul les
corbeaux troublent le calme fermé depuis
les années 2000 pour cause de rénovation
trop onéreuse la piscine est un vestige
d'une époque aujourd'hui révolue le
grand toboggan autrefois source de rire
et d'éclaboussure existe toujours mais
il mène vers une eau sombre qui invite
assez peu à la baignade la nature a donc
repris ses droits les herbes et les rond
sont envahi l'espace créant un
labyrinthe végétal où l'on pourrait
presque s'attendre à rencontrer des
personnages effrayants la maison du
gardien autrefois lieu de vie est
aujourd'hui un cocon de solitude ou un
vieux lavabo ou un siège de toilette
arraché témoigne de la présence humaine
les vestiè avec leur porte rouges
numéroté raconent des histoires de jours
ensoleillé et de plongeons joyeux ce
lieu qui a vu tant de joie et de vie est
aujourd'hui un chapitre clos de
l'histoire locale une mémoire du temps
où l'eau était claire et les rires
raisonnaient sous le soleil de mes dents